I'm so wired around the Protestant work
ethic mentality in the way that I was
raised and in the evidence that my mind
points to like I would rather just grind
and sweat and like you know have
sleepless nights but ultimately it is an
unsustainable energy source so the idea
that you are going to release that and
instead be in a place of receiving
presence acceptance and ease is so
uncomfortable and what if it was easy
what if you could just allow it to
happen and it would happen adopt a
mindset of abundance do the work but not
attach the suffering and the Toil and
the pain to the work and be in a in this
place of like allowing
[Music]